just to finish on this point it's the
first time I thing I saw brother Imran
and I've one thing I learn and love from
him was that whenever he will see his
mom or dad he would go straight and kiss
them on the head so much thank you guys
thank you for waiting for me here I know
my father got a summation when I go home
because I know it's because with atheism
and agnosticism and these types of
things which which take off and
obviously Connor is a product of this
you know secretary secular and liberal
program you lose all these morals you
lose all these values you lose all this
sacredness for parents you know this
journey this road that I travel on it
all seems crazy over the years up in
2002 Tagalongs inspired by my story from
a true for now where my clothes had
holes in them I froze picky to the night
east maschino and Versace my snow laces
in Iraqis new millennium ceremony
commentary better care to brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are well inshallah so we're here at the
salams videos we do some time today in
Leicester Square and obviously everybody
knows about the death of Habib's father
and we folk will share some interest
we'll go over some videos where their
moments to give off grappling and maybe
watch a video where when honey became
that you know champion in the UFC how is
that fair about that and then we're
going to talk about we always talk about
the rights of the mothers but the
fathers and how one should be with their
father is very important and I think
it's not given its due right and so
that's what we're gonna do in short so
we're gonna get straight into it
possible look good yeah no that's good
just keep this mic here so this is the
first reaction after no it's the second
reaction of support because we've done
all yesterday oh yeah yes yeah so it's
interesting to have a reaction video
okay we're gonna watch this video
[Music]
what could first reaction when you see
father and son wrestling yeah you can
see this for love you can see this love
because he disrespect who he was not
going for it who he was like putting in
I was about to say that yeah yeah Kobe
was putting in enough effort to just
make it look like spring an effort and
clearly you can see you know his
father's age he can he can do something
and you know Kobe is just you can see
the love the use of [ __ ] yeah
so it's I was gonna say that as well you
can see that I don't think I'm surprised
by I don't know hubby would maybe you
know put his duck butt in there
cold shot or should I say you know maybe
some Italy it's it's rude you know you
know floor it's it's it's it's rude and
you can see he's not even he's pretty
enough effort in for the move but it's
not really you know so much thank you
guys thank you for waiting for me here I
know my my father gonna smash we're
gonna go home because I know he's got
smashed and Nevada sorry
Vegas sorry and alhamdulillah undisputed
undefeated which the right to a champion
thank you so so look in up show like
awesome you know his father passed away
there's so many lessons to be learned in
Habib's I wouldn't think it's Korea
because we know it's Korea is not really
permissible in Islam you know hold this
question about it but as an adept as
etiquettes as one how the fatherly son
relationship I think it was a good role
model both for them to know and this is
something that we lack in our generation
you know speak the elders and the elders
will say how the respect has been lost
towards them there's no respect anymore
yeah and to me personally when we were
studying Alabama fraud by Inman Bihari
it's quite interesting you know because
he compiled all the hadees and
narrations of the process of cinnamon
add up an etiquette of everything but
from your neighbors to your mum to your
children to your father to your mother
to your auntie to your granddad it
covers everything and when I was reading
that book interestingly it would talk a
lot about for example when you're with
your father you don't walk in front of
your father
yeah when you're sitting down you wait
for your dad if I'm not mistaken your
data sit down first you do not call your
dad by his name no in some certain
cultures some even say that you don't
even look at that in ice yeah so this is
something that's been lost we have today
and look let's be real mothers and
fathers sometimes it can be difficult to
live with real let's not sugarcoat this
there are times where like this can be a
variety of reasons for like people that
the family's not Muslim
it can be hard they could be using Islam
against you etcetera but for those who
have families almost limbs it could be
you know this father's our fathers Judy
I'm trying to say yeah they're always
gonna be a harder ug I'm trying to say
and that is their form of showing love
this doesn't generalize like there's
sometimes moms are harsher than the
father's yeah but generally I think they
were a fine example and they left the
fine legacy that how their relationship
should be because even when looking at
how even is all when I go home at that's
gonna smash me yeah who says that who
says at the age at the age and that
shows the respect that he has is because
the respect that he has for his family
members
and you know with teenagers you get this
thing from a year from teenage and then
it carries on which is kind of like you
can't tell me what to do
don't tell me what you could do I'm
gonna move out of home I know what I'm
doing
here's a champion here's somebody who's
a lion yes saying and he's happy he's
happy saying my dad's gonna beat me
right so he just shows you the level of
respect and care and you know even if
you look at the earlier on the insults
that were given by Connor to his father
you see in some cultures that respect
for the father's loss to the point that
you can't even cost someone's father
because it's not gonna work it's gonna
be like your father's like this yeah my
father's like that like people are gonna
bother defending their fathers in some
cultures right so with you know and I
think this is so powerful by Islam and
culture that Islam wherever it goes it
inculcates this type of strong cultural
values which just become fused into
society yeah so your father says do this
you do that your mother says do this and
you do that right regardless of I mean
look at him right
he's even worried about okay I did this
thing off to the ring IIIi did these
actions my dad's gonna be me now think
of his adversary think of Connor right
he's treating women like objects you can
see he's going out clubbing drinking
he's he's doing this he punched an old
guy yeah yeah but you won't really find
like you know oh oh my god my dad's
gonna beat me oh my god my family's
honour what about this it's all gone
yeah all of that stuff is gone sadly
these things did exist in the West when
Christianity was stronger here because
Christianity of course is way better
than being an atheist right I mean of
course we're not Christians and we
disagree with them theologically but
it's better than being an atheist right
and because with atheism and agnosticism
and these types of things which which
take off and obviously Connors a product
of this you know secre a secular liberal
program if you lose all these morals you
these values lose all this sacredness
for parents you know before you were
saying early in the car that you know I
think in the Kurdish culture that you
would kiss the hand and then you put the
forehead for your elders and you know
imagine they like trying to do that I
don't know in public yeah people will be
like oh you know that's that looks odd
or even youngsters today but these were
traditional values that held societies
together exactly by losing exactly and
we're losing them because we're losing
ourself and that's very evident both on
the sisters will you guys understand I
love you guys watching this you might
have issues with your mom or the father
in the context of yes you don't agree
etc but that is your test
Allah will test you one way or another
some people are test with their wife
something like this with their husbands
some people test with their children and
you will be tested with your parents
I lost the panel Tyler says to Pamela
that after worshiping me do not be good
to your parents even look even if
they're disbelievers Brahman sisters
yeah we believe this belief as a
pinnacle commit to shirk but Allah says
do not obey them in that but be gentle
and kind with mbone sisters
so if allah subhanaw taala saying that
[ __ ] is something i will never forgive
if your parents are committing that yeah
and by the way I'm gonna say I'm going
to send people to the Hellfire those who
acknowledge I knew it was the truth and
committed [ __ ] if your parents are doing
that be merciful to them wow this is
ours rights that they're violating Allah
saying that's between me and them you do
your right to your parents this is
amazing bro you give the rights to your
parents because they boil you they
looked after you and the contrast is
amazing because the parents are doing
work Allah is the one who frees them to
cause them they're being ungrateful to
Allah Allah saying in the context of I
would that's between me and my slave but
you but what they're doing to me you
don't do it to them and this is what I'm
seeing blonde sisters sometimes yes you
want to pull your hair out but please
please rely it's a form of a bad and
worship but if your mom is doing
something to enrage you
and this that that you try your best you
try one like that Avada that is strength
because that's your mom imagine somebody
in region what's what you want to do
like this slap punched if somebody else
yeah but with parents if you do that and
let's honor our fathers as well yeah
because they go out there and they work
hard and sadly a lot of youngsters do
not value and appreciate that your
father's working doing this and your
subhanallah behind closed doors or
outside doing all kinds of stuff on
sisters I love that if you want Jenna
I'll be very honest with my sisters if
you want general ly your doors are
Palace I don't know which to have it was
who was crying so much when his mother
or father passed away and he said the
reason why because my daughter Janice
have gone because that's my opportunity
you know and so Brahmin sisters it's a
fine example that Habib and his father's
left to us helped a father and son would
father and daughter or mother and
daughter or mother and son the
relationship one should have with their
parents should be utmost respect and
mercy and try your best brothers and
sisters because what lie I'll tell you
something I've I don't think I've seen
examples of people disobeying their
parents I have not seen them prosper I
have not seen them prosper we're not
talking about here parents to other
limbs literally beating you up we're not
talking about that yet that you should
still respectfully move that the house
find our solutions etc but those who
oppress their family members yet
unnecessarily them their parents
specifically blown sisters do not wait
for anybody in your life well why he
don't and like I said before brown
sisters inshallah less if you're
watching this while I appreciate your
father how Bebe's father's gone he would
give the whole world to spend more years
with him brothers and sisters and he did
not know this was going to happen
so if we have fathers acknowledge that
in strong my bond sisters be kind to
them and yeah that's that's all I can
say is a you know just about this one
thing which I because I've lost my
father many many years ago a mother a
few years ago and you know there's
something very deep and profound in the
core
Allah says you know to us to make to
keep you grateful to Allah to worship
Allah this straight off place as parents
and why is that because the parents at
the end of the day they they are the
ones who have taken sacrifices which you
only really appreciate once your parent
everyone says that mom is thinner and
only when you you know when you go
through those struggles like you know at
the moment there's a recession we had it
was the recession things are getting bad
and you know you're just gonna be like
working working working imagine the fact
that our parents shouted us from all of
these problems and they took care of us
so you know whoever's watching just you
know and ensure that we want the reward
for this as well do good to your parents
because you don't know how long they're
gonna be about hmm exactly dawn sisters
hope you guys benefited from this
inshallah I would say right now if you
means go with your mom or your dad and
it shall kiss him in the forehead in
Charlotte and that should be a form of
respect which I personally I'll be
honest really just to finish on this
point it's the first time I think I saw
brother Imran which was talking about
today and I've one thing I learned a lot
from him was that whenever he will see
his mom or that he would cost rate and
kiss them on the head and I just
remembered it reminded him you know we
have our differences but he still
preferred that look I love and I care
for but that's something that it's I
remembered that I would do with my mom
now my mom or my dad even my dad at
times when he's peak you know smashing
me yeah you know I tried to implement
and I think that's a beautiful thing
cousin oh no come in and kissing the
head-bobbing sisters may love this you
guys in Charlotte so next time
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better get